قبل زلزال كان هذا المقهى وسط السوق
التاريخي في كهرمان مرعش مقصدا للزوار
لكنه اليوم بات ملاذا اخيرا لعائلات سوريه
لاجئه تقطعت بها السبل والامال بعدما دمرت
منازلها في زلزال وباتت اليوم بلا ماوى
مطلبها الوحيد خيمه
المشكله انه زلمه تركي الله يكثر خيره
اعطانا هالخيمه هي قهوه بركنا فيها الزلمه
بده يشتغل بده يشتغل زلمة بدنا من اهل
الخير شيدر انه نبرك
وعنا اثنين عجز في دين امهم البيت انخرف
هون وفي ايدين امهم وابوهم عاجز لانه
طالبين قصر ولنا طيبين مملكه طيبين خيم
شوادر بس 18 يوم والله العظيم تحت المطر
والبرد الارض من تحتهم ما زالت تواصل
اهتزازها وامطار تهطل من السماء فوقهم
تضيق الدنيا عليهم ومعها امال صمود
الاطفال امام رخاوه الارض وغضب الشتاء
الاولاد لا في صوبه لافته في لافي انه غسل
طيب منين نروح نحن نجيب نحن هيك امر الله
وصار فينا مثل اهو اليوم القيامه احنا
ثلاث عيلات
وعندي عمي مريض سكر كمان لا عنده دواء
الله عم بيلحس بالليل دوخه ايش بدنا نشربه
لا عنا لا في صيدليات فاتحه
اضافه للاطفال الصغار هناك مسن مريض بداء
السكري ويحتاج لعلاج فوري
بالنسبه للدوله مع مال احسن امنه المشفى
زحمه كثير زحمه يعني واحد بخجل من زياد
نفسه تشوف حالات حرجه يطلب علاجها للسكر
والله الاولاد مسهل بارد بارد كثير برد
يعني بالليل بوظ بوظ ميكن بوز بالليل
الولاد
بس الاطفال ما عم تتحمل ولا خرج يتحملوا
ويبقى اقصى ما تعانيه هذه العوائل وجود
اثنين من الاطفال العجز دون رعايه وادويه
لتضاف ماساه جديده الى ماس ليس اقلها غياب
الخيمه زيدان زنجلو العربيه كهرمان مرعش